dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol jonai fahir today
you will see the power of human
Ingenuity supercharged by an AI as we
are living the Advent of aib's image
generation we now have several tools
that are so easy to use we just enter a
piece of text and out comes a beautiful
image now you are asking okay karway
they are easy to use but for whom well
good news we now have a new solution
called stable diffusion where the model
weights and the full source code are
available for free for everyone finally
we talked a bit about this before and
once again I cannot overstate how
amazing this is I am completely
Spellbound by how the community has
worked together to bring this project to
life and you fellow Scholars just kept
on improving it and it harnesses is the
greatest asset of humanity and that is
the power of the community working
together and I cannot believe how much
stable diffusion has improved in just
the last few weeks don't believe it well
let's have a look together at 10 amazing
examples of how the community is already
using it one today the image generation
works so inexpensively that we don't
even need to necessarily generate our
own we can even look at this amazing
repository where we enter the prompt and
can find thousands and thousands of
generated images for that concept yes
even for Napoleon cats we have thousands
of hits
so good now additionally we can also add
a Twist to it by photographing something
in real life obtaining a text prompt for
it and Bam it finds similar images that
were synthesized by stable diffusion
this is very a generation of sorts but
piggybacking on images that have been
synthesized already therefore we can
choose from a large gallery of these
Works two by using a little trickery and
the image impainting feature we can now
create these amazing infinite Zoom
images
so good three whenever we build
something really cool with Legos we can
now ask stable diffusion to re-imagine
what it would look like if it were a
real object the results are by no means
perfect but based on what it comes up
with it really seems to understand what
is being built here and what its rear
counterpart would look like I love it 4
after generating a flat 2D image with
stable diffusion with other techniques
we can obtain a depth map which
describes how far different objects are
from the camera now that is something
that we've seen before however now in
adobe's After Effects look we can create
this little video with a parallax effect
absolutely incredible
5. have a look at this cat night I love
the eyes and all of these gorgeous
details on the armor this image really
tells a story but what is even better is
that not only the prompt is available
but also stable diffusion is a free and
open source model so we can pop the hood
reuse the same parameters as the author
and get a reproduction of the very same
image and it is also much easier to edit
it this way if we wish to see anything
changed 6. if we are not the most
skilled artist we can draw a really
rudimentary owl hand it to the AI and it
will draw the rest of this fine owl
seven and if you think the drawing to
image example was amazing now hold on to
your papers for this one this fellow
scholar had a crazy idea look these
screenshots of old Sierra video game
games were given to the algorithm and
there is no way right well let's see oh
wow look at that the results are
absolutely incredible I love how closely
it follows the framing and the mood of
the original photos I have to be honest
some of these feel good to go as they
are what a time to be alive
eight with these new web apps variant
generation is now way easier and faster
than before it is now as simple as
dropping in an image by the way a link
to each of these is available in the
video description and their source code
is available as well nine in an earlier
episode we had a look at how artists are
already using Dolly 2 in the industry to
make a photo of something and
miraculously extend it almost infinitely
this is called texture synthesis and no
seems anywhere to be seen and now these
fellow Scholars seamless texture
generation is now possible in stable
diffusion too not too many years ago we
needed not only a proper handcrafted
computer Graphics algorithm to even have
a fighting chance to create something
like this but implementing a bunch of
these techniques was also also required
because different algorithms did well on
different examples and now just one tool
that can do it all how cool is that
and 10 stable diffusion itself is also
being improved oh yes this new version
adds super resolution to the mix which
enables us to synthesize even more
details and even higher resolution
images with it this thing is improving
so quickly we can barely keep up with it
so which one was your favorite let me
know in the comments below and once
again this is my favorite type of work
which is free and open for everyone so I
would like you fellow Scholars to also
take out your digital wrenches and
create something new and amazing let the
experiment begin this episode is brought
to you by any scale the company behind
Rey the fastest growing open source
framework for scalable Ai and scalable
python thousands of organizations use
Rey including open AI Uber Amazon
Spotify Netflix and more hooray less
developers iterate Faster by providing
common infrastructure for scaling data
ingest and pre-processing machine
learning training deep learning hyper
parameter tuning model serving and more
all while integrating seamlessly with
the rest of the machine learning
ecosystem any scale is a fully managed
Ray platform that allows teams to bring
products to Market Faster by eliminating
the need to manage infrastructure and by
enabling new AI capabilities array and
any scale can do recommendation systems
time series forecasting document
understanding image processing
Industrial Automation and more go to
anyscale.com papers and try it out today
our thanks to any scale for helping us
make better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time